-Our next guest is
a five-time Emmy-nominated
and Golden Globe
Award-winning actress
you know for her portrayal
of Samantha Jones
in "Sex and the City."
She produces and stars
in the new show "Filthy Rich,"
which airs Mondays on Fox.
Let's take a look.
-You will give up
this MMMA thing.
-MMA?
-You are Jesús's only parent.
And if you get hurt,
who will he have?
Besides, I would
very much like for you
to join my security team.
-She just put you on staff, bro.
-It is an entry-level position
that you can build on.
-Jason, wherever he is,
he will close
that ganja factory.
And...Ginger.
-Here it comes.
-You and your mother,
you will leave New Orleans.
You will close that porn site
of yours, and you will never,
ever speak to any member
of the press ever again.
-Please welcome to the show
Kim Cattrall!
Thanks for being here, Kim.
How are you?
-I'm great. Nice to see you.
-Nice to see you, as well.
And congratulations
are in order.
You are a new --
a brand-new U.S. citizen.
-I am, proudly.
August 17th, I became a citizen.
I took the test and passed.
There were six --
There were ten questions,
and I got the first six right,
so they said, "Okay,
you can become a citizen."
-You really -- You joined us
at a great time, Kim.
You really got in
while the gettin's good.
-You need my vote.
-That's true.
Welcome aboard, and we're
very happy to have you.
Before we get to your show,
which I am looking forward
to talking about,
we had a mutual friend --
We've talked on this show
about his sad passing
due to COVID --
Hal Willner, who was
the music supervisor at "SNL."
But I did not realize you
were close with Hal, as well.
-Yeah.
I met Hal through Lou Reed.
They were doing the radio show
together, and we became,
you know, really close
within that circle of friends.
He was the first person
that we lost to COVID,
so it was really sad.
My partner and I, Russ,
we were in New York
till about end of April.
And then we got on a plane
and went up to Vancouver Island
where my mom is
to make sure she'd be okay.
And I brought
this little mini pod
that, Hal,
a few birthdays before,
had put over 2,000 songs
of his music on for me.
So I felt -- You know,
we were all grieving Hal,
but every morning,
every afternoon,
I just had his music
in the room in the house,
so that was comforting.
-He was a man of so many skills,
but that ability
to curate a musical list
based on the taste
of his friends was really --
it was -- it was something else.
He will definitely be missed.
You -- You have
a wonderful, new show.
You play -- This is about
a very rich family in the South
who has a Christian TV network.
And we learn pretty early on --
A lot happens in the pilot.
That the patriarch
of this family, your husband,
is maybe not living
to the values
that he espouses on television.
-That's right.
-Are you enjoying the show
so far?
-Oh, my God, yes.
It's great to play a woman,
you know, who has that
most feminine of qualities --
balls.
She's very ballsy.
She's very stubborn.
She's very controlling.
And I really enjoyed,
you know --
I don't know that much
about religion per se.
I was never brought up
with any religion.
My mother was agnostic.
My dad never really
made it to church.
So I wanted to sort of
understand more about
what it would be like
to be an evangelical.
And I didn't want to do
the Tammy Faye routine.
I wanted to make her
much more complex than that,
which I hopefully think
we have achieved.
-And I know you are
a producer on this, as well.
Is it more interesting
when you get to have
a say in the character
and make those choices
from behind the scenes, as well?
-Oh, it is. I mean, I'm --
I'm a woman of a certain age.
And I didn't want
to dumb her down at all.
And I love strong,
powerful women.
So I wanted to oversee that.
I wanted to have a say in that.
I produced another show
called "Sensitive Skin,"
and that was my first
producing outing.
And I -- I just loved it.
I really, really enjoyed
the creative elements of it.
I didn't have anything to do
with the raising of the money
or anything like that,
which I don't think
I'd be as good at.
But what --
Creatively, it was --
it was definitely an avenue
that I want to pursue further.
-I've heard you say that
you were drawn to the character
because it wasn't like anything
you'd seen before.
I have to imagine, as an actor,
it's so exciting
when you're looking
through a script
and you have that realization
that this is not a version of
something you're familiar with.
-Absolutely.
Especially in your sixties.
You know, I played
my first grandmother role
about a year and a half ago.
And, you know, I wanted
very much to expound on that
because, as you know,
you get older,
you have so many
more stories to tell.
You have so much more to give,
as far as information.
Not just about yourself
but what that age, you know,
entitles you to
and the challenges of it.
But for me, I love the camp
element of "Filthy Rich."
You know, I love the fact
that I could be that theatrical
but also be very subtle
at the same time.
This character was very broad
but very intricately drawn.
And, so, I read the script
that Tate Taylor,
the executive producer
and creator of it, sent me.
And the first question
that I asked him was,
"What happens next?"
Which is always a really good
sign that there's --
you're in new territory.
-You shoot this show
in New Orleans.
And I would say food is
a really nice part of the show.
Especially, the idea of, like,
how food is a communal
experience with family.
-Yes.
-And I guess family
is the only place left
we're having
communal food experiences.
-Or any kind of communal.
-I know, right?
And then, at some point,
you realize,
"Oh, there's a reason
I went out with people
that weren't my family."
-Yeah. Exactly.
-You sort of --
Obviously,
it's a great city for food.
And you pulled in a bunch
of restaurants and chefs
to be involved
in the making of the show.
Were they enthusiastic
to be part of it?
-Oh, my God, yes.
I mean, and there's --
there's so much to the cuisine.
I had no idea
what a hummingbird cake was.
I'd never heard of a hummingbird
cake or any of those things.
So, I'd been to New Orleans,
but I never really experienced
what it's really like
to live there.
We were -- In the first season,
we were there for about
seven months all in total.
And it's -- it's friendly.
It's welcoming.
It's crazy and zany.
But it also has this
little bit of danger to it,
and I'm not just talking spices.
-Lastly, I did not
know this about you.
This was a real
unknown fact for me.
That you are a fan
of the Premier League.
Not only that, but you --
A second congratulations
in order.
You support Liverpool, who won
the Premier League last year.
Congratulations again.
-We are -- We are the champions.
Thank you.
Now, I just have
a question for you.
How did West Ham happen?
-Yeah.
It's a really good question.
I was -- This is a true story,
though -- I was in --
I was doing a show in London
in late -- in the late '90s.
And I wanted to see
a Premier League game.
And I went to a ticket agent,
and it was that or Arsenal.
And you could argue
I made a terrible choice.
-Well, I think you made
two terrible choices.
-[ Laughs ] But I think --
I think I deserve credit
for sticking with my bad choice
because --
-You do. You do.
That's commendable.
You know,
when you are born in Liverpool
and both of your parents
are Liverpudlian,
you're either for Everton
or you're a Red.
And my dad was a Red.
So you have no choice.
-You had no choice.
I have a very similar thing
with my father and --
and the Pittsburgh Steelers.
I will say this.
West Ham is playing Everton
on Wednesday.
So maybe you could
at least root for me, then.
-Okay.
-[ Laughter ]
-How dare you. You know what?
You're a bad winner.
You're the champion,
and you should be nicer
to people like me.
-We've waited a long time.
-You -- And it's well-deserved.
Thank you for being here.
It's lovely to talk to you.
-Oh, pleasure. Thanks so much.